I am deeply from Long Branch New Jersey
probably the town in which American
celebrity was infant invented the old
idea of high society went to Saratoga
Springs and Newport Rhode Island Long
Branch was near New York City and it's
where the patent medicine millionaires
and the show business people went at the
time not as high class gradually that
has taken over and is what society used
to be President Garfield and President
Grant went to Long Branch Garfield died
in Long Branch Diamond Jim Brady took
Lee and Russell there it was the summer
White House six or seven different
presidents including Woodrow Wilson it's
a very historic resort town and the town
motto could almost be the town isn't
what it used to be so I grew up
surrounded by a kind of elegiac feeling
there was an oceanfront when I was a kid
there's a boardwalk and honky tonk and
also my family had been in the town I
was the third generation my mom and dad
both graduated from Long Branch high
school as did my aunt's and uncle's my
cousin's my brother and sister had the
same homeroom teachers my dad so long
branch gave me a sense of the past
perhaps the sense of elegy a sense
typically for small towns a sense of
belonging and a sense that one really
wants to get the hell out my particular
dream life takes place in a kind of a
large town or small city everybody
probably has it terrain in which that
takes place and for me it's a place with
streets water near an ocean or
river and it sold
you